إلى أي مدى ستكون متأكدًا من قدرتك على
التغلب على اعتراضات تركيا وما
الذي يتطلبه الأمر لتسريع عملية
الانضمام إلى السويد ، نحن
نتطلع إلى إجراء حوار وثيق مع
تركيا على مستويات مختلفة ، كما
أننا مستعدون للذهاب إلى تركيا
لمناقشة القضايا التي قد تواجهها تركيا مع
السويد السويدية كعضو في الناتو ، لذلك
نتطلع أيضًا إلى أن نكون قادرين
على إقامة علاقة ثنائية أوثق مع
تركيا عندما نصبح أعضاء في الناتو
، هل أنت واثق من قدرتك على ذلك؟
تحقق أنك طلبت
إجراء مكالمات هاتفية مع الرئيس أردوغان ، هل
أعاد مكالماتك ، هل تحصل على
جاذبية بشأن هذه المسألة في الوقت الحالي ،
لقد أوضحنا لتركيا بوضوح
أننا مستعدون للتحدث ، فنحن مستعدون للذهاب
إلى تركيا والحصول على
المناقشات الثنائية حول الطريق إلى الأمام ،
لذلك نحن على استعداد للقيام بدورنا
، قلل الرئيس بوتين الآن من
التعليقات السابقة التي أدلى بها حول
مقاومة
انضمام السويد وفنلندا إلى الناتو ،
ما نوع الانتقام الروسي؟  يمكن أن
تتوقع السويد
أننا لا نعرف ولكننا جاهزون ومستعدون
إذا كان هناك انتقام ، لكنني لاحظت أيضًا أن
أه
لم يكن كل هذا
الصراحة عندما يتعلق الأمر بالتهديدات
تجاه السويد بالطبع نحن نرحب بذلك
كثيرًا.  يعني أن هذا جزء من
النظام الأمني ​​الأوروبي ، كل دولة
لها حقها في اتخاذ
قراراتها وقرارنا بالانضمام إلى الناتو ليس
شيئًا نفعله ضد روسيا نحن
نفعل ذلك من أجل أمننا.